sommes en ligne avec sylvain kahn
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
professeur de géopolitique de l'europe à
à sciences po certains espéraient encore
hier que la paix était encore possible
mais vladimir poutine a choisi le chemin
de la guerre c'est clair
oui c'est clair effectivement on est
bien obligé de le constater
les américains depuis plus d'un mois 10
ont crié au loup et manifestement ils
étaient très très bien informés et ils
avaient ils ont eu raison de partager
ces informations avec nous alors ce
matin ce qui est très important de
souligner c'est que c'est toute
l'ukraine que la russie attaque nous ne
sommes plus seulement dans l'est de
l'ukraine dans les régions séparatistes
de deux nièces kelvink quel est le but
ultime de la russie selon vous
le but ultime de l'état russe vont je
préfère parler de l'état russe ou de
l'administration poutine parce que rien
n'indique à ce stade que cette
le déclenchement de cette guerre et
cette invasion militaire de l'ukraine
par l'armée russe et l'assentiment de la
population et du peuple russe donc le
but de l'administration poutine s'est
très probablement de vassaliser
l'ukraine de la même manière qu'eux
poutine est parvenu sans recourir à la
guerre vassaliser la biélorussie et dans
une certaine mesure
mick d'asie centrale et dans une autre
mesure l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie on
voit bien depuis quelques années que
manifestement l'objectif de politique
étrangère de vladimir poutine et de
reconstituer dans ce qu'on appelle
l'espace postsoviétique
disons une aire d'influencé par tous les
moyens et par la force au mépris du
droit au mépris de la volonté des
populations et de la démocratie donc on
peu disons analyser ce qui s'est passé
depuis deux mois comme une tentative par
l'administration poutine de parvenir à
cette fin vassalisation de l'ukraine
l'installation d'un gouvernement pro
russe à kiev
renoncement par kiev pour toujours de
l'entrée dans l'otan et dans lieux
poutine a essayé d'obtenir cela il n'y
est pas arrivé
les pays de l'otan et de l'occident en
général ainsi que les pays de l'ue ont
clairement refusé tout cela donc il est
passé on va dire
aux dernières instruments ou dernier
moyen d'obtenir cela l'invasion
militaire puisque les occidentaux
avaient clairement dit qu en cas
d'invasion militaire
il ne s'y opposerait pas par la force
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est très
compliqué je veux dire faut pas oublier
que la russie c'est une des trois plus
grande puissance militaire du monde
d'autant plus que
l'armée russe a été considérablement
modernisé la tester son efficacité
grandeur nature lors de la guerre en
syrie en 2015 c'est une puissance
nucléaire enfin c'est à dire que on sait
que s'il
envisageait de s'opposer par la force
militaire cette agression de l'ukraine
et bien on prendrait le risque de tomber
dans un conflit nucléaire c'est bon la
russie c'est pas n'importe quoi si j'ose
dire du point de vue militaire kokolo
l'ajax en comment les occidentaux
excusez-moi de vous couper mais comment
du coup les en bridant tous peuvent
réagir
et vous vous poser la bonne question
c'est pas le moment de faire de l'humour
noir mais comme comme a dit un rustre
est très connu au début du xxème siècle
que faire
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
que il est clair que chez les européens
et en particulier on l'a bien vu en
pologne dans les trois états baltes
en particulier ça fait des années que on
est alerté disons sur la menace russe
bon mais partout dans toute l'ue vous
avez des analystes et des hommes
politiques ou des femmes politiques qui
disent attention l'état russe n'est pas
un pays voisin c'est un pays adverse 1
et qui est très dangereux pour autant
comment faire baisser il faut il faut
réfléchir pour trouver la bonne réponse
parce que c'est sûr que si on s'engage
dans un conflit militaire
ça peut mener à une guerre nucléaire au
coeur de l'enfant il faut quand même
bien avoir en tête que la russie s'est
non seulement 2700 km de frontière
commune avec l'union européenne
la finlande la pologne les trois pays
baltes qui sont de l'estonie la lettonie
la lituanie mais c'est aussi l'enclavé
de kaliningrad ça veut dire que au coeur
du territoire européen il ya un petit
morceau de l'état russe on s'en souvient
notamment parce que quatre matches du
mondial 2018 ont été commis là-bas à
kaliningrad où on avait construit enfin
bien russe avait construit un stade
flambant neuf et depuis 2015 il ya des
missiles et 16 26 de courte portée qui
en un quart d'heure peuvent envoyer des
ogives nucléaires sur toutes les villes
d'europe donc je vous dis pas qu'il ya
pas de réponse pour moi je suis pas un
spécialiste en stratégie ni et a
fortiori je suis pas du tout un
militaire je vous dis pas qu'il ya pas
de réponse mais en tous les cas
la réponse n'est pas simple alors on
pourrait aussi considérer que à la tête
de l'état russe en ce moment il ya
quelqu'un qui qui fait rentrer l'état
russe disons dans une dans une attitude
et une démarche très déraisonnable et
peut-être manière rationnelle et qu' il
faut peut-être considéré que au sein des
élites russes il ya des appuis avec
lesquels on pourrait sur lesquelles on
pourrait jouer pour changer le cours des
orientations de la politique russe voyez
les se compliquer c'est très très
compliqué les occidentaux n'envisagent
pas pour l'instant a priori de réaction
armée
d'opérations sur le terrain pas encore
pour l'instant il devrait y avoir plutôt
des sanctions économiques mais on l'a vu
après l'annexion de la crimée en 2014
ces sanctions économiques n'ont pas
vraiment eu d'effet est ce qu'elles sont
pavel ces sanctions qui vont être
décidée même si elles sont plus fortes
que le train de sanctions qui a déjà été
décidé depuis le début de la semaine
vous savez le mieux me du bien donc
c'est pas parce que la politique de
sanctions de l'union européenne des pays
ocde
n'ont pas dissuadé le régime poutine
d'envahir l'ukraine comme il est en
train de le faire que les sanctions
n'ont eu aucun effet malgré tout on a
mis là mais la pression
par rapport à 2014 les sanctions ont
évolué ce sont devenus des sanctions
très très ciblées qui touchent
directement et si j'ose dire directement
au portefeuille et dans leur vie
professionnelle et familiale
un grand nombre plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui font partie de ce qu'on va
appeler la nomenclatura russe
bon c'est peut-être un travail de sable
qui va finir par porter ses fruits vous
voyez c'est à dire on est bien obligé
encore une fois de je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui l'opinion publique
européenne et même américaine est prête
à envoyer 500 mille hommes pour sa
survie l'homme ou fans 138 soldats en
tout cas pour défendre l'ukraine en
prenant le risque d'une guerre nucléaire
ou d'un envahissement de l'europe par
l'armée russe vous voyez c'est à dire on
n'est pas responsable
1 on a très envie d'aider les ukrainiens
et je pense que même collectivement la
société civile le lait mais il ya le
monde académique tout le monde on peut
tous se demander comment on peut
soutenir à nous de façon à notre échelle
un peu comme c'était ça s'était passé en
1981 quand il y avait eu l'état de siège
en pologne et qu'il y avait eu un
immense mouvement de solidarité partout
en europe pour soutenir les polonais on
peut sans doute se demander chacun à sa
place et dans sa vie professionnelle et
sociale comment on peut aider les
ukrainiens et après on peut aussi
réfléchir au niveau des états comme on
peut agir en tant qu'etat mais bon on
n'est pas comment dire on n'est pas
responsable du fait qu à la tête de la
russie il ya un homme qui ne respecte ni
l'état de droit ni la légalité ni les
sociétés civiles ni les individus ni la
démocratie
c'est
atroce c'est tragique pour les
ukrainiens et donc il faut qu'on trouve
les moyens de les aider mais on n'est
pas responsable du fait que l'état russe
se comporte comme il se comporte avec
mes recettes un homme qui manifestement
ne respectent rien un homme qui serait
devenu fou même pour certains merci
beaucoup